[Musique]
est-ce que ça te dérange que je ne sois pas
complètement humain tu étais la personne la plus humaine
que j'aie jamais rencontrée
dois être responsable de
[Musique]
quelqu'un de très spécial
hé gamin pas seulement une adolescente hé
quel est ton problème tu ne te souviens pas de
quoi tu veux dire doc t'a trouvé dans la
casse donc tu dois être de là-haut
et je suis juste  une fille insignifiante
c'est ce qu'ils veulent que tu penses
je ne suis pas ta fille je ne sais pas ce que
je suis je fais
tu es l'arme la plus avancée de tous les temps
mais ce n'est qu'un obus ce n'est ni mauvais ni
bon cette partie dépend de toi
je  ne supporte pas
la présence du mal
elle menace l'ordre naturel des
choses
ce soir n'est pas un jeu
c'est un coeur
j'ai besoin de toi pour détruire la fille appelée
Aleta
tu as fait la plus grosse erreur de ta
vie
et qu'est ce que c'est
sous estimer qui je suis
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous